une entrée en scène moins flamboyante
qu'en 2015 la foule et moins nombreuses
les écrans géants ont disparu devant
reed aux halles les nouveaux ministres
sont arrivés on a un gouvernement qui
veut se donner un air plus modestes on a
beaucoup de travail devant nous pour
livrer pour les canadiens sur leurs
attentes élevées de eux-mêmes et de leur
avenir et c'est exactement l'équipe pour
le faire avec un gouvernement
minoritaire le premier ministre mise
plus que jamais sur ses joueurs de
confiance l'étoile libéral christophe
willem est nommé vice première ministre
une marque de confiance surtout elle
devient ministre des affaires
intergouvernementales
après les négociations difficiles avec
l'administration tremblay ses talents de
diplomate sont maintenant requis à la
maison elle aura la lourde tâche de
gérer des relations tendues avec des
pros baisse et d'apaiser les divisions
pays aujourd'hui en 2019
je pense que les canadiens comprend que
non défis les plus importants sont plus
domestique le pouvoir la voir dans une
position de force au niveau domestique
au niveau des affaires
intergouvernementales et à mes côtés en
tant que vice première ministre
ça va être bon pour l'unité nationale
face à la montée du bloc
justin trudeau envoie un message et
donne des promotions à des québécois de
son équipe
françois philippe champagne devient
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves duclos sera désormais président du
conseil du trésor
mélanie joly monte en grade et les
maintenant responsable du développement
économique
en plus des langues officielles justin
trudeau accepte finalement de nommer un
lieutenant du québec pablo rodriguez qui
sera aussi leader du gouvernement en
chambre
vous avez dit ce québécois au cabinet
j'avais un lieutenant du québec et vous
avez une équipe qui veut inquiet qui va
travailler de façon très dynamique avec
la main tendue je jure fidélité et
député montréalais marc miller fait son
entrée au service aux autochtones
l'écologiste vedette steven guilbeault
arrive au cabinet mais pas où on
l'attendait il prend les rênes de
patrimoine canadien
il se défend d'être devenu
un spectateur sur l'enjeu qui lui tient
le plus à coeur l'environnement c'est
pas la faire d'une personne au sein du
gouvernement ça doit être une priorité
gouvernementale est clairement ça l'est
mais qui le dossier de l'environnement
revient plutôt à john wilkinson de la
colombie-britannique question de faire
le pont avec l'ouest malgré ses ennuis
de santé l'ancien ministre jean corps
devient représentant spécial du premier
ministre pour les prairies en même temps
tous nos ministres vont avoir la
responsabilité dans tous les différents
dossiers d'être connecté sur le terrain
avec les leaders avec les représentants
avec des gens d'affaires dans les
différentes communautés à travers
l'ouest et à travers le pays pour
s'assurer qu'on écoute bien les
préoccupations des gens un cabinet de 36
ministres au total deux de plus qu'à la
dissolution de la chambre des
conservateurs n'y voit pas le changement
espéré
essentiellement ce sont les mêmes
visages des mêmes objectifs avec les
mêmes échecs
donc monsieur trudeau a manqué son
rendez vous avec une nouvelle approche
pour diriger le canada quelle est la
priorité de ces nominations là ça a
l'air d'un espèce de buffets à volonté
justin trudeau veut montrer qu'il a
écouté les canadiens mais son vrai test
viendra aux communes dans quelques
semaines quand viendra le temps de
négocier avec l'opposition et que son
équipe sera confronté à la houle de
gouvernement minoritaire
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa